with me here today I brought something
beautiful this is a feather from one of
the most beautiful birds we have in
Kenya the crested guineafowl but this
feather is more than just that if you've
taken time when you're outdoors to look
at the feathers around you you'll have
noticed that is this huge variety of
different sizes shapes and even colors
the feather is one of the most
astonishing pieces of technology
invented by the natural world and for
centuries this favour has helped birds
to keep dry to keep warm and even power
flights only one section of the Tree of
Life can actually make a feather
among all the world's animals birds are
the only ones who can make something
like what I'm holding today I personally
have given them a nickname and I like to
call them the feather makers it is the
major difference between birds in any
other animals we have on earth and if
you can't make a feather you cannot call
yourself a bad for us humans who are
earthbound buds represent freedom this
feather has a label buds to conquer
gravity and take to the air in an
extraordinary way don't you sometimes
wish you could fly like a bird but a my
passion and I want to change the way
each one of you thinks about them the
easiest reason I love them so much
it's because they are beautiful there
are 10,000 species in the world and each
one of them is uniquely beautiful buds
are amazing and this talk is dedicated
to all the birds of the virus
in deals these birds have been part of
our lives and cultures all over the
world for centuries and every society
has a story about birds you'll probably
have had childhood stories of different
birds and how they relate with man
I personally recently launched that our
human ancestors would follow flocks of
vultures and then they will help them to
identify where carcasses have been
dropped by large carnivores and these
humans will scavenge any part of that
meat
birds have been used as brands and
labels all over the world you know the
bald eagle it was chosen as the national
emblem for the u.s. because of its
majestic strength beautiful looks and
even a long lifespan and just like us
humans who've managed to live in
virtually all habitats of desire but
have also conquered the world from birds
such as this beautiful penguins that
live in the cold ice caps to even others
like the lacs who live in the hottest
deserts you can imagine
indeed this species of conquer this
world but also build houses like us the
real pros in house building are a group
of birds called the Weaver birds and
this name they were given because of the
way in which they weave their nests an
interesting one but as a larva - just
like a sea Owens in fact you'll be
surprised to know that males dressed to
impress the women and I'll show you how
so here we have a long-tailed video
button and this is how he will normally
look but when it comes to the breeding
season everything changes and this is
how he looks
yeah but also multiple species of them
do love to touch and cuddle just like
humans and I know you're wondering about
this one yes they kiss too
sometimes very deeply
some have even learned to cheat on their
spouses for example the African jacana
the females will mate with multiple
males and then it takes off to find
other males to mate with and she leaves
the male behind to take care of the
chicks and birds help us so much and
they play very crucial roles in our
ecosystems each day
vultures clean up our environments by
literally digesting disease-causing
pathogens and they finish carcasses that
will otherwise cost us lots of money to
clear from the environment a sizeable
flock of vultures is capable of bringing
down a caucus the size of a zebra
straight to the bone within just about
30 minutes ours help to read the
environments of rodents and this helps
us a lot because it saves us money we
don't lose our crops and secondly we
don't have to buy harmful chemicals to
handle these rodents the beautiful sand
birds we see in our environments a part
of nature's pollination crew and they
help our plants to form fruits together
with other pollinators like insects they
have actually helped us to get most of
the food crops that we depend on for
many years unfortunately the story of
birds is by far not perfect they are
faced by numerous challenges every day
wherever they live top on the threats
facing Birds is habitat loss and reduced
food availability birds are also hunted
especially migratory species and ducks
that congregate in water bodies
poisoning is happening to flocks that
like to stick together especially in
places like Christ schemes
moreover power lines are electrocuting
birds and wind farms are slicing birds
when they fly through the blades
recently we've had the talk of climate
change making a lot of headlines and
it's also affecting birds because birds
are being forced to migrate to better
breeding and feeding grounds because
unfortunately where they used to live is
normal
habitable my own perspective to us buds
was changed when I was a small boy in
high school and there was this boy who
struck injuring the wing and the leg of
a bad we called the auger buzzer I was
standing there just a mere photinia
walls and I imagined of a human being in
a similar situation because this bird
could not help itself so even if I was
hardly any biologist by them I gathered
with three of my friends and we decided
to house the bug until it had regained
strength and then let it free
interestingly he accepted to feed on
beef from a school kitchen and we hunted
termites around the compound for its
dinner every day after a few days it had
regained strength and we released it we
was so happy to see it flap its wings
and fly off gracefully and that
experience changed the way we looked at
birds we went on to actually make a
magazine and we call it the hawk
magazine and this was a known of this
bird that we had helped with in our own
high school those experiences in high
school made me the conservationist I am
today and a passion for birds should
especially matter for Africa and all
Africans because among all other
continents Africa hosts some of the most
amazing bird species you can find
anywhere in the world
imagine having a name like Shoebill
that's the name of that bird and there
are countries like dr congo Tanzania
Uganda and Kenya who are leading the
continent in highest numbers of
diversity when it comes to the species
these birds continue to provide the
continent with very crucial core system
services that Africa needs moreover
there is huge potential for Africa to
lead the world in avian tourism the
economy will definitely benefit imagine
how many communities will benefit from
groups of tourists visiting their
villages just to see the endemic birds
that can only be found in those villages
how can we help birds together there is
now a
for all of you to turn your passion for
buds into contributing to their
continued survival and you can do that
by becoming a citizen scientist citizen
science is a growing trend around the
world and we are having scenarios where
people are sharing information with the
rest of the community about traffic
updates security alerts and so on that
is exactly what we realized as bad
watches and we thought because birds are
found everywhere if we got all of you
and everyone else in Africa to tell us
the buzz they find where they live where
they school or even where they work then
we can be able to come up with a map of
every single species and from there
scientists will be able to actually
prioritize conservation efforts to those
habitats that matter the most take for
example these two projects the African
Raptor data bank which is mapping all
birds of prey in the continent of Africa
and the Kenya bird map which is mapping
about 1,100 species that occur in my
country Kenya these two projects now
have online databases that are allowing
people to submit data and this is
converted into very interactive web
sites that the public can consume and
make decisions from but when we started
there was a big challenge we received
many complaints from Bad Watchers and
they will say I'm in a village and I
cannot access a computer how do I tell
you what birds live in my home or where
a school or where I work so we were
forced to renovate our strategy and come
up with a sustainable solution it was
easy we immediately realized that mobile
phones were becoming increasingly common
in Africa and most of the regions could
get access to her so we came up with
mobile phone applications that you can
use on your iPhone and on your Android
phone and we made them freely available
for everybody watch enthusiastic person
out there so we came up with bad Lisa
which is used by the Kenya bad map and
also we have the African Raptor
observations which is now used by the
African Raptor data bank this was a huge
breakthrough in our work and it
made us get enormous amounts of data
from everybody out there in the regions
with this we realize that citizen sense
is indeed very powerful
the reason being citizen science is
adaptive and we were able to actually
convert many bird watchers to start
sharing now information with us when we
were studying we didn't know that birds
could be a huge gateway to approaching
conservation of other forms of animals
interestingly now the virtual museum for
Africa we have maps for dragonflies and
damselflies butterflies and moths
reptiles frogs orchids spiders scorpions
and yes we were mapping mushrooms could
have imagined mapping mushrooms so these
shoulders that indeed we've created a
community of people who care about
nature in Africa I hereby call upon all
of you to join me in promoting the value
of birds within your communities please
just tell your friends about birds for
we are always inclined to love and care
for that which we know please spend a
few minutes in your free time when you
are at work at school or maybe at home
to at least look around you and see
which beautiful birds are there come
join us in citizen science and tell us
the buzz you are finding in a places
where you visit even simpler you could
buy a child or your sibling a pair of
binoculars or a bad book and let them
just appreciate how beautiful these
birds are because maybe one day
do we want to care for that one which
they know and love the children indeed
are our future let us please teach them
to love our fellow makers because the
love of birds can be a huge gateway to
appreciating all forms of nature thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]